I called Immuniletics. Immuniletics is where is the company that sells the little Petri dish plates where you could buy to test your home for a mold.
As you suggested after I did my micotox test, she didn't think they'd come up with anything different than the inspector.
We had over to test the molds in the house. Maybe I misunderstood why you wanted me to do their testing in addition.
I suggested that you do their testing in addition simply because I was not completely familiar with everything.
The type of testing that you're inspected and they suggested you at least call them and talk to them.
So if this at the gallon, Immuniletics didn't think that they would come up with anything different than that's just fine.
Second on that topic, I had elevated citrinated ochre toxic A and this other micotox that I will ruin the pronunciation on according to my micotox test.
I had indicated on my last cheek swab that pass mold exposure may have contributed my cancer.
How would a past exposure still be coming out in my urine are toxins stored somewhere?
Yes, toxins are stored somewhere.
So when you're exposed to toxins of any kind, whether it's poisons from the air that you breathe or chemicals from gasoline that you just pumped or glyphosate from what you just sprayed on your yard or what you just ate in your food, or micotoxins produced from black mold in a building that you worked in 10 years ago,
those toxins go into your body.
Now, again, how do toxins get out of your body?
Rate of toxic uptake through the rate of toxicification, whatever it exceeds the rate of your ability to detoxify, then your body has to put more than some of it.
And toxins cannot just keep circulating in your bloodstream.
So your bloodstream, they go through your arterial walls, they go into the extracellular space, and they get stored all over your body.
So they can get stored in the extracellular space, they can get stored in the cell membranes themselves, the phospholibular bilayer of a cell membrane, they can get stored inside of a cell, fat cells have an affinity to store toxins.
And that's how your body protects you from basically becoming poisoned and dying from the poison, it stores toxins typically in your fat cells.
That's the danger of losing weight too quickly, you will break down fat inside the fat cells and you'll break down toxins inside the fat cells and you'll liberate them into the extracellular spaces where they're carried.
Remember by what the lymphatic system back to the venous system, back to the liver, hopefully then getting dispiled into the small intestine, going through 30 feet of your intestine into the toilet.
Now there's all sorts of problems that can come up through that whole flow through that river of expelling toxins, you can reabsorb them in the gut again and they go back into the bloodstream and they get dumped back into the extracellular spaces and go back right back into some of them.
So toxins get stored in your body forever, so you will die with lots of toxins, so if you donate your body to some functional medicine test that they may have in the future when you die and we do a smear of your cells somewhere your liver, we will find toxins, there's poisons there.
There's a level of toxins that damage cells, so those toxins to all sorts of damage to the cell, these micro toxins do damage to the cell there oxidizing agents, they can damage cell membranes, if they get inside the nucleus of the cell member inside the cell is like a little New York city, all the activity that's taking place in every single cell of your body, which there's millions and billions and millions of it.
So, but the nucleus of the cell, which is involved with replication, biosus of new cells creating new cells that can become damaged if any one of these toxins damages that nucleus that nucleus can one damage can cause the cell to go into rapid replication replicating cells that are in rapid replication.
That's called cancer, so what causes cancer, the answer is anything that gets inside a cell and can damage the nucleus and increase the rate of replication of the cell.
So, can be toxins, can be biotoxins, living organisms, can be radiation, can be lots of things, so they can stay in your body for a long time and then you can expel them when you start doing detoxification procedures, you start living healthier that will help you get rid of them.
So, let's say you do a mycotox test like this person did and you have elevated mycotoxins, should you do something about it?
Yes, but most of you are already doing things about it, you are already taking tea laders and binders and things, already have you on those things.
So, the truth is that what were the question really is, what were the levels of those mycotoxins six months ago, 12 months ago, 18 months ago, or years ago?
Well, we can't go back in time to know those things, but the question is then where did they come from? Well, that's why you got to find out whatever you do a mycotox test or any toxic exposure test, whether it's a stool sample test or whatever.
You got to go where are they coming from, is it from current exposure?
Because if you have current exposure of mycotoxins, you could be working on your detox pathways and keylating agents and binders until your eyes turned green.
And you're not going to have a whole lot of success if your level of toxicification is the is exceeds your your rate of detoxification, you're going to be coming more and more poison.
So, you know, it behooves us to ask that question, do I have current exposure? Now, if you determine that, you know what, I don't have any current exposure, this is all from past exposure.
Okay, well, they just keep doing what you're doing, you know, you're doing songs, you're doing coffee, you're doing all these, you know, nutrition to help all this stuff up, there's nothing else you need to do them.
Okay, you just want to make sure, make sure, make sure that you don't have current exposure. That's why I always suggest, you know, they're not that expensive to run a couple tests on your house open on your car.
People can get these molds from different things, are you going to a church every Sunday that has full of bones and you're breathing that in, are you going to, you know, a doctor's office that's full of mold and you're breathing.
You know, I don't know, you know, you have to place your lock homes and look for current exposure. So nobody knows that unless you test for it.
Could it be from foods is another part of the question. Yeah, can be so, you know, peanut butter, common spot for Michael talks and pickup.
So, yeah, you know, I know people that are addicted to eating, you know, giant amounts of peanut butter on a regular basis, could that be an exposure of, you know, they should run a Michael talks test.
They don't have any Michael toxins and they could probably continue to behavior.
So that's what goes into things you just want to be like a Sherlock Holmes looking for these things.
And then run another Michael talks test, you know, if you have two Michael talks tests within a period of time, let's say you do another one at six months of your levels.
After all that you're doing are even higher, you have some courage exposure somewhere, you've got to figure this out.
So if they're continually to drop, then hey, okay, we could have been totally a past exposure and it takes, it does take a long time to get this stuff out of your book.